[Música]
en Ecuador una comisión multipartidista
de la asamblea nacional recomendó un
juicio político contra el presidente
Guillermo lasso la sugerencia se da en
medio de una investigación por un
supuesto entramado de corrupción en las
empresas públicas del sector eléctrico
tenemos análisis
con críticas hacia la justicia el
presidente argentino Alberto Fernández
marcó su discurso que inaugura el año
legislativo el mandatario arremetió
contra medios de comunicación
empresarios e integrantes del poder
político y Judicial a los que acusó de
estar detrás de la condena contra su
vicepresidenta Cristina Fernández de
kirchner
continuó el drama de miles de pasajeros
que quedaron varados en Colombia luego
de que viva Air la aerolínea de bajo
costo suspendiera sus operaciones la
compañía dijo que no tiene la capacidad
de devolver el dinero a los damnificados
les explicamos qué originó este problema
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Ecuador donde la comisión del caso
encuentro aprobó por seis votos a favor
y uno en contra un informe en el que
recomienda un juicio político contra el
presidente Guillermo lasso las
acusaciones para recomendar este
enjuiciamiento están enmarcadas en
artículos de la constitución que
refieren a delitos contra la seguridad
conclusión cohecho peculado y
enriquecimiento ilícito el informe que
no tiene carácter vinculante pasará al
pleno que fue convocado para el próximo
sábado con el fin de adoptar una
resolución previamente hablamos con
Wendy Reyes analista política y
profesora de George Washington
University quien nos explicó Cuál es el
proceso a seguir para que se lleve a
cabo un juicio político
y efectivamente en Ecuador
un marco constitucional que permite tres
causales para el enjuiciamiento político
la primera son delitos contra la
seguridad del Estado la segunda contra
delitos contra la administración Pública
que es la causal que está utilizando
precisamente esta comisión y el tercero
es delitos de lesa humanidad en este
caso el informe de la comisión no es
vinculante Es decir puede está
recomendando el enjuiciamiento político
pero el el trabajo que tiene que hacer
los legisladores es necesitan
precisamente cuarenta y seis firmas que
permitan y llegue al cal que es el
órgano legislativo más fuerte digamos el
que está encima del pleno de la asamblea
Constituyente constitucional y entonces
tiene que este cal aprobar Qué pasa si
existen estas cuarenta y seis firmas que
acusan al presidente por una de las
causales de enjuiciamiento político Lo
que sucede es que el cal este órgano
legislativo de la asamblea nacional
envía a la corte constitucional todo
depende del
afirmativo de la corte constitucional la
corte constitucional tiene que valorar
si efectivamente estas causales tienen
que ver con el delito que están
imputando Y si es que esto tiene
relación o no es cuando si es que se da
el positivo de la corte constitucional
regresa al cal y Tendría que ir al pleno
de la asamblea nacional en donde
necesitan dos terceras partes de los
votos para el enjuiciamiento político y
todo el proceso que sería que existan
las en la etapa de prueba del presidente
etcétera no Y esto más o menos tomaría
un mes y medio
en Argentina comenzó un nuevo año
parlamentario y la sesión de apertura
estuvo a cargo del presidente Alberto
Fernández pronunció un discurso en el
que tocó varios temas como la
integración económica de América Latina
a través del mercosur y la situación de
Derechos Humanos en la región pero sus
dardos al poder judicial y a los medios
de comunicación constituyeron el centro
de su intervención en medio de un tenso
ambiente político en Argentina de Cara a
las presidenciales de octubre Samuel
Salgado nos ha pedido
la sesión de apertura del año
parlamentario fue el escenario el
reencuentro entre Cristina y Alberto que
Desde hacía seis meses no se veían
debido a las tensiones políticas al
interior del oficialismo sin embargo
Alberto pronunció un discurso alineado
con la vicepresidenta y desatado contra
el poder judicial y los medios de
comunicación de sirve semejante trabajo
si miembros de la justicia y del
ministerio público se entrelazan en
vínculos poco transparentes con
empresarios o emisarios de la política
que operan como Auténticos factores de
poder una puya directa del presidente a
la Corte Suprema por la condena de seis
años de prisión a Cristina Fernández por
corrupción
situación con una condena en primera
instancia a la vicepresidenta de la
nación
en el terreno económico Fernández
También estuvo a la ofensiva recordó su
lucha contra el fondo monetario
internacional y la deuda externa para
atribuir victorias económicas a su
gobierno el presidente priorizó la
generación de empleos y el crecimiento
del pib sobre la alta inflación que en
el año fiscal 2022 llegó al
94,8% representando un problema
estructural en Argentina somos uno de
los países que más creció en estos dos
últimos años todas las proyecciones
propias y de los organismos
internacionales señalan que en 2023
volveremos a crecer el fortalecimiento
de mercosur y el respeto por los
Derechos Humanos también estuvieron en
la agenda del discurso Alberto Fernández
que fue un balance político y no un
lanzamiento electoral ya que aún es
incierto si quiere salir a buscar un
nuevo mandato y en otras noticias de
Argentina la pagó masivo que se originó
tras un incendio dejó sin electricidad
grandes franjas del país en medio de una
ola de calor que aumenta la demanda de
energía en Buenos Aires la situación
generó interrupción en el servicio de
trenes y se unió a millones de personas
en la oscuridad afectando a tiendas y
restaurantes de acuerdo con la
secretaría de energía las regiones
centrales de Santa Fe neuquén Córdoba y
Mendoza también sufrieron apagones
y en varios aeropuertos de América
Latina y en particular en Colombia El
cese de operaciones de la aerolínea viva
aérea ha dejado varados a cientos de
pasajeros el gobierno de Colombia no
descarta intervenir en el sector aéreo
en protección de los usuarios ante una
declaratoria de quiebra de la empresa
que Aparentemente venía arrastrando
varios problemas financieros y buscaba
integrarse con su principal rival la
aerolínea Avianca
en varios aeropuertos de América Latina
la gente se acumula en los pasillos el
motivo no pueden volar tras el cese de
operaciones de la aerolínea colombiana
viva Air el lunes en la tarde la gente
llegó al aeropuerto con su pasaje pero
no les dejaron pasar el control
puerta 6
pero de allá me mandaron para acá
absolutamente nadie nos responde Aunque
este desenlace no viene de la nada de
hecho se ha podido intuir en los últimos
meses como muchas otras aerolíneas viva
él sufrió las consecuencias económicas
de la pandemia motivo por el que los
directivos tomaron una decisión
integrarse con Avianca la mayor compañía
aérea colombiana no obstante la
aeronáutica civil entre regulador
colombiano no ha tomado una decisión al
respecto de la alianza pese las
continuas solicitudes de las aerolíneas
adjudicando seguir los lineamientos del
proceso de revisión tras decidir dejar
cinco aviones en tierra algo que ya
suponía el despido de empleados
finalmente viva era anunció el cese de
operaciones algo que algunos han
interpretado como un intento de presión
al organismo gubernamental pero que la
compañía ha negado
viva no tomó Este paso drástico para
presionar al gobierno se tomó porque
nuestra realidad es que estamos en
crisis financiera
Este martes algunos de sus trabajadores
se manifestaron delante del edificio del
aeronáutica civil pero el ente ha
asegurado que ha dado opciones Air y que
su posición atiende al interés de los
pasajeros se abrió la oportunidad de
presentar condicionamientos o remedios
que pudieran permitir la integración sin
afectar la libre competencia velando
siempre por el interés del mercado Y en
especial de los pasajeros
en medio de este revuelo el gobierno de
Colombia descartó salvar la compañía y
planteó la posible intervención del
mercado aéreo para dar garantías a los
usuarios
pasamos a Venezuela el dos veces
candidato a la presidencia Enrique
capriles intentará nuevamente llegar al
palacio de Miraflores el líder opositor
resultó ser el favorito en una consulta
realizada entre las bases de su
formación y ahora representará su
partido primero justicia en las
primarias que se llevarán a cabo el 22
de octubre unos comicios en los que se
conocerá Quién será el candidato de la
oposición que se enfrentará al
oficialismo en las elecciones
presidenciales previstas para 2024
desde hoy les decimos tenemos candidato
presidenciales Enrique
la tercera dosis pero también hemos
tenido a través de un proceso directo
democrático extraordinario la selección
de un abanderado presidencial que sale
con muchísima fuerza
a recorrer todo Venezuela y a llenar a
Venezuela de esa expectativa Clara de un
triunfo para derrotar un triunfo en las
primarias y un triunfo para derrotar a
Nicolás maduro y cerramos en Chile con
el descubrimiento de un nuevo moai una
de las características estatuas de la
isla de Pascua y que constituye el
principal atractivo turístico de este
lugar el hallazgo se realizó el pasado
21 de Febrero en el centro de una laguna
que comenzó a secarse desde 2018 y que
está ubicada en el cráter del volcán
rano raraku según los expertos la figura
de 1.60 metros de largo puede abrir una
nueva perspectiva de la historia de la
isla y de sus antepasados
hasta aquí este informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]